why was the ending for the flash redone
three times and how did this help lead
to one of the biggest surprise cameos in
the film keep watching to find out
morning spoilers for The Flash ahead in
the new DC Superhero tale The Flash
Barry Allen and the Flash finds out that
whizzing back to the past to save his
mother from dying drastically alter's
history moving forward however Barry's
quandary becomes more complicated as he
enters alternate timelines on Earth
where he meets his younger self and
different iterations of the characters
he previously partnered with in the
Justice League the Multiverse angle of
course allowed director Andy muskete to
tap into the DC Movie Vault at Warner
Brothers as such the filmmaker was able
to bring back Michael Keaton's version
of Bruce Wayne Batman from director Tim
Burton's Batman movies and craft the
story to replace Henry cavill's version
of Superman with Sasha Kaye a Supergirl
in a in the Multiverse approach allowed
Michael Shannon's General zard who died
at the hands of cavil's Superman in Man
of Steel in 2013 to get another crack at
taking over Earth in the flash as a
result Barry desperately tries to reset
his timeline and return to his version
of Earth while his efforts first appear
successful he's surprised to see that a
superhero from a previous DC film makes
a stunning appearance to conclude the
movie according to the Hollywood
Reporter the conclusion viewers are
getting in the flash is actually the
last of three endings filmed by muskete
which transpired under three different
sets of leaders of Warner Brothers
thr said the first ending was filmed
under the auspices of Warner Brothers
Chief Toby Emerick and DC boss Walter
Hamada the second transpired in the
studio chairpersons and CEOs Michael
Deluca and Pamela Abdi and a third
happened under the watch of current DC
Studios co-ceos James Gunn and Peter
Safran thr said the first ending for the
flash which was filmed during Toby
emmerich and Walter Hamada's tenure of
Warner Brothers revealed that Barry
Allen the Flash's attempt to reset the
timeline didn't happen as such Michael
Keaton's Batman and Sasha kaye's
Supergirl who died at the hands of
Michael Shannon's General Zod in the
final version of The Flash ended up
Surviving and appeared on the courthouse
steps after a pivotal hearing involving
Barry at the end of the film thr said
his version was actually seen by test
audiences several times however the
first version of the ending was tossed
in 2022 when Michael Deluca and Pamela
Abdi took the Reigns of Warner Brothers
after the studio merged with Discovery
as a result the publication noted a new
courthouse steps films that included
Keaton and Kanye as well as Henry
cavill's Superman and gal gadot's Wonder
Woman the addition of the latter two DC
Stars was deemed a strategic move by the
new studio bosses since Cavill was
poised to make a cameo turn in Dwayne
Johnson's Black Adam and the third
Wonder Woman movie was in development
however Andy muskete was forced to
return to the drawing board again as the
second flash ending was thrown out on
James Gunn and Peter saffron were
brought to board when James Gunn and
Peter saffron announced their DC
Universe reboot in January 2023 it
became clear that much of what was
created by DC directors Zack Snyder and
Patty Jenkins would not be part of the
new DC Universe the news wasn't too big
of a surprise though since fans in
December 2022 learned Henry Cavill
wouldn't return a Superman and plans for
Wonder Woman 3 were reportedly being
scrapped luckily for Gal Gadot fans her
Wonder Woman remained in the DC fold
with cameos and Shazam Fury of the Gods
and the Flash your dad's turn in the
final version of The Flash didn't come
in the last scene but in the film's
First Act in addition the deaths of
Keaton's Batman and Supergirl by General
Zod earlier in the film stayed intact
and caval's Superman was no longer a
factor instead gun and saffron pulled
off perhaps the biggest surprise of the
film when Ezra Miller's Barry first
talks to Bruce Wayne by phone as a
billionaire made his way to the
courthouse only to see George Clooney's
iteration of the character emerge from a
limousine and exclaim who the are
you
according to thr gun and saffron thought
land including to a price as role as
Bruce Wayne Batman was unlikely but the
actor agreed to make the appearance
after he liked what he saw in the nearly
completed version of The Flash thr said
that Clooney shot The Cameo with Miller
in January Warner Brothers kept such a
tight lid on the Batman and Robin star's
appearance that the scene wasn't even
revealed to theater owners and the film
screened at Cinema Khan in April